how do self awareness self assessment
and self-improvement begin and how do
they continue over time well they're all
tied together and it starts with being
self-aware with being able to detach
because if you if you can't detach from
yourself then you can't see yourself and
so people ask well then how do you
detach from yourself how do you learn to
do that and a good drill for this is try
to imagine the way other people see you
and what other people are thinking of
you and one place where this happens and
it definitely happened to me is when I
started getting put in charge of things
I started thinking about other people's
perspectives
what are they seeing if you're in charge
then what are your subordinates see you
do what are your subordinates here you
say what kind of representation are they
receiving in if you work for someone
else it's the same questions what does
the boss see me do what does the boss
hear me say what kind of representation
am i making of myself to my boss and
then you start thinking about what are
your friends and family think what do
they see what do they hear and so the
question becomes how well do you
represent yourself what shortfalls do
you have now when you first start
looking it's like you're looking at an
overgrown lawn there are some big
obvious problems so you do a broad just
kind of general cut of the grass
you fix some of the big easy problems
that are obvious or once you've done
that you've gotten rid of some of those
big obvious problems you notice some
more detailed problems say then you
handle them and once you've got those
handled you see even smaller and more
detailed issues so you start trying to
fix them and that's what you do with
yourself you continually detach and then
you look and then you refine and then
you detach and then you look and then
you refine and then you detach and you
look and then you refine that's what you
do that's how you get better and that
process doesn't stop it can't stop
because if you stop refining then and
then the weeds grow back and the next
thing you know you can't see yourself
anymore and you can't see yourself
anymore when you stop looking at you
yourself then you accept you accept
anything and that's wrong don't accept
the faults don't give yourself the
benefit of the doubt you've got to be
your own harshest critic and hold the
line and don't let go